You have to ask why it is that you would
if you were a postmodernist yourself,
why it is that you would privilege
the idea of power above all else.
It's exactly what is it that
you're pushing to the margin,
and so that's something that
we're going to talk about.
Now,
here's one thing you
might push to the margin.
Let's say that you believe that
hierarchies are a consequence of power.
Well then you push competence to the
margin and then applying the postmodern
mark modernist logic.
You might say,
well,
the reason you're privileging power is
so that you can produce so that you could
push competence to the margin,
and so you want to keep that in mind too,
because that's going to become important.
As we discussed the relationship
between postmodernism and Marxism,
maybe you're after the destruction
of the idea of competence itself.